I am Matthew McConaughey this is Anne
Hathaway we are in a new film called
serenity it's a very serious intense
film so we're gonna play a very serious
intense game co-star equations Chris
Pratt our Chris Pratt you are the
respect to u plus Chris Pratt equals I
was in Bride Wars with Chris Pratt Dave
now anything happen okay so who was in
Bride Wars with us yeah that was where
is she she was just there hey hey was in
Bride Wars oh yeah
which means it's coming it's coming I
think it comes to me it's bound to come
to me and say something like halel is
guiding today's equals equals Matthew
McConaughey now I understand the game
websley 101 ended now the dog probably
for the plan some more people love that
dog and come out to me go how is what
was the name the dog's name I forget
anyway people come up on the street and
go house songs I'm like who and they go
the dog and How to Lose a Guy in 10 days
have you I have I wish oh man
oh god yourself I know you guys were in
whereas it was it or is it this one
evening wedding the matter was daily two
times in the wedding planner
Stanley know anything I feel like a Judy
Greer jaegers Judy Greer which brings us
back to the one that loving other drugs
it's not Kevin Bacon its G Babar it's
Judy Greer there we go we're still
correct everywhere right right that
about another way was Italy touch okay
[Music]
she's over on me where is it
hmm Oh she'd date with one of your very
good friends Sandra Bullock time to kill
which springs back what kind of a this
is easier than I thought I go what was
your favorite I mean I can't tell you my
most favorite because she asked me not
to
I checked and she said oh maybe not that
story I have a few but one of my
favorite ones was when we were filming
the scene in the Met Ball
I had wrapped but my kid was already
asleep and everyone was still there so I
was just hanging out and we just kind of
each poured it tequila and talked so we
were just sitting in you know the office
area of the Med with you know all this
having priceless historic art in the
other room and all we were doing was
sitting back there getting drunk
together talking so that was my favorite
one she's been in three movies with him
I was in two movies with him too - I
don't want so that's it's agree together
which means we know we know all of each
other's secrets through all these people
and then now going to tell you
[Music]